specials but the maitre d is Alex's best
mate is Gavin's first job as a
restaurant manager and a don't think has
got a clue couple portions left very
nice I did have that for dinner price
started highly recommended okay it
doesn't help a Gavin supported front of
house by Emily Alex's girlfriend the
chicken was told 70 degrees in
appropriate time today
anything wasn't cold her only experience
of serving food comes from seven years
as an air hostess that's why I crave
everything you are the maitre d I'm that
you running the place you've got to get
some Authority around you know that
you've got to get some presence look at
those profiteroles over there that's how
big your bowl up should be that big now
find them and [ __ ] use them just
drizzle Alex doesn't come Alex isn't
doing too badly but as not long before
Gavin's way out he's dead you should be
taking orders man
what is he doing out there Davin's
managed to get 60 people booked in for
tonight but he's allowed 40 of them to
arrive at the same time I think we were
being the [ __ ] intimidated I'm in a
[ __ ] Club huh any manager worth his
weight should know he's got to stagger
the bookings to keep a steady flow of
orders coming into the kitchen you okay
yeah yeah yeah good you done looking
scrape off the dome
put it out oh yeah well is it tell me
what is you know here we go again no
returns
we're still not one under pressure all
annexes bad habits come flooding back
[ __ ] order first time is entire
career he's actually had to cook
properly and it's pretty obvious he
can't do
completely in the [ __ ] and lost it
big-time
nothing together from people and he's
just clammed up and and I've got a good
mind to get that number play off that
[ __ ] car and stick it up his ass
sideways
Alex and Gavin are like two little boys
playing at running a restaurant never
worked like this I hate saying it but so
close to cowboys yeah that quick now
yeah
put the rest up for sale